you know what here here so done kicked
in my doing put me into trouble our car
that is correct
so Damon it was last May that you wrote
a very impassioned speech to the
watchman fans in a letter now that the
show is almost premiering is there
anything more you'd like to add oh my
god if I didn't cover it in those but 19
pages it got it was way too long it
probably I probably said too much
already
just said hope you like it
XO Damon winky face I I think that I
just wanted to say I'm a huge fan of
this thing Watchmen it it's largely
responsible for every everything that I
know and love about writing it inspired
me dear lord I hope I don't screw it up
I instead I said all that in seven pages
now you're taking the original graphic
novels and kind of using them as a
springboard to jump forward 30 years and
to kind of see what our world is like
now for the fans out there who have not
read the graphic novels would you say
that they can jump right into the series
or do you want them to do a little
research I'll say Yaya when did had you
read it I had I had tiptoed down that
down that Lane just a little bit on a
friend's recommendation but I hadn't
read it in totality I've read maybe
three three chapters or something now
it's probably a good time to ask you
does the show make sense to you it's
nice it's nice to watch it because you
know you you know it's nice to have a
little bit of context because you can
pick them on some of the hints and
things like that but even without the
hints I'm able to you know I'm able to
follow them in the show but I think I
think the fans will definitely be able
to tune in it and follow and then
hopefully go back and you know look for
the clues how much fun did you have
planting those little Easter eggs so
that the fans of the graphic novels
would have new things to discover
I think Watchmen for me invented the
idea of Easter eggs this comic book had
so many hidden details you had to read
each issue three or four times to find
things and you know we had point and say
like oh my god this refers back to
something an issue 1 etc etc and if you
read these you know these transcripts in
the back of an issue you learn this
thing about this character who to
justice etc etc so I
turned it from Watchmen and then I put
it into lost and now it's nice to kind
of come back to watchman and say just so
we're clear this is where I stole this
so there are a lot of eggs literal
literal eggs in Watchmen and they are
they are Easter eggs it is an omelet of
a television show there we go
it's so nice to meet Cal you play of
course Regina's king's on-screen husband
and you guys have such an amazing
on-screen chemistry in connection
together how did you guys find that
dynamic it's all through play I mean
Regina makes it so easy to work with
just you know the first time that I met
her in the you know in the Testament you
don't mean you know I go in and and she
was so so warm and so generous it makes
it really easy to easy to play you know
when you have an actor who's who's just
game you know she's always at the top of
her game is she really put put me at
ease and made it really easy to go in to
do my job and to throw her balls and
she's just always so playful we couldn't
be sort of poke at each other a lot in
between the takes and it makes it really
fun to let that energy transition over
over over into the scenes Regina was
kind enough to read with a couple of
different options although as soon as we
saw an episode of Handmaid's Tale that
the Yaya was in we were like get us that
and so she she did her readings with
everyone she's like what do you think
we're like oh you know and she's like
well costume Thanks what was your
reaction each of yours when you saw the
full sister night outfit for the very
first time on Regina I thought it was so
cool I've never seen Regina doing
anything like that and to know how
excited she was about about stepping
into that so on the one hand you know it
was a really really cool costume it's
you know seeing her dressed up in that
way but I had a lot of fun watching her
and joy being dressed up like that for
the first time and going out it was it
was dope for me we you know it's one of
those things where you write a script
and you just say she just looks like a
super cool nun and then shared Davis our
costume designer is like what is this
super cool nun that you you keep writing
about like this is sort of like
actioning nun and so we had that we had
to try
a number of different outfits a Regina
was very game some of them were complete
and utter bust from the from the jump
but some of them were suddenly like okay
there it is there it is there it is and
when she ward that outfit for the first
time
everyone just looked at each other and
said there she is yeah well Damon you'd
mentioned hiding your easter eggs and of
course you did that so beautifully and
lost this series is like a continuation
of the watchmen graphic novels we're in
the day and age of reboots reunions
everyone's dying to know if lost will
get some sort of treatment put it on the
record for us what can you tell us my
feeling is that just like Watchmen was
someone else's story or Star Trek was
someone else's story and then you kind
of pass the baton and things go on I
personally am NOT going to be involved
with any more versions of lost because
we told the most complete version and I
feel like I spent four years of my life
begging them to end it when they finally
said yes that the ending that we did is
probably should should stand as our
ending that said I know that it's
inevitable that someone else is going to
come along and say I have a new idea for
lost and I'm kind of excited about it
and very curious about it I think that
would be you know sort of immensely
flattering and super exciting to see
what someone else would do with it well
lastly as fans are about to dive into
Watchmen there are so many things that
I'm excited for them to explore I wish I
could rewatch every episode again for
the first time what is the one thing
that you think fans should know before
they tune in oh great question I break
it out that it's not a remake yes I
think fans to know that it's not a
remake and they should come I'm not sure
with what to expect but don't expect a
remake and I think it would look as
funny as that as much as as much as we
say that as much as I say that much of
this literature out there still come to
the scenes expected expecting the remake
but you know then they'll they'll have
something else you know to latch on to
it to go back into and to discourse
about yeah and I would say that they
should probably know that in November of
1985 a an enormous alien squid and
landed in the middle of New York City
and killed three million people that's
probably the only thing that you
- no okay good if that sounds weird
you've come to the right place